okay so this is highly highly stressful
to get up in front of writing
while since I've done this so I'll do
the best I can the i guess i should
mention you know when Tom was on my
board heey the first thing he did first
when you first started talking about
it's like what are you guys I'm trying
to figure out are you guys or
not because life's too short to work
with and so that was even those
the first conversation we talked about
when he was talking about being on the
board and in the first the first
official board meeting we had after we
took money from Excel guy named peter
fenton Mitch cape or Mitch Mitch was
there and Tom came in in a niche said
Tom the last time I saw you was on the
board meeting for this incredibly
defunct company oh my god so the last
collaboration they had done was the
company to gone out of business so but
it really worked better than that not
yeah Tom Tom did all right so one of the
first things you do when you're trying
to figure out a talk is you you're
trying to figure out a title and I
thought about this a long time I thought
about a lot of I've rejected many titles
so this is the tile I decided I decided
to give how to give a job like mine so
it's a fun it's it's a reference so one
of my favorite authors has got named
kurt vonnegut and he gave many talks
during his career they were all named
how to get a job like mine where he
would give that he would say this is the
talk when I give and he would get up and
talk about whatever he wanted to talk
about he never talked about how to get a
job like his the UM one time you said
people should use fewer semicolons
that's about all he did in terms of that
but I liked I liked it because Kurt Kurt
was interesting he built a career that
didn't look like anybody else's career
and in a funny way like a lot of the
things that Kurt Vonnegut road it's kind
of humorous and absurd on the surface
but there was a real truth to it because
what he was I think my point of view is
that what he's really saying is like the
way to get a job like mine it's like
well I'm just me be who you are and try
to figure that out and then don't try to
be anybody else and don't try to get a
lost his job just be just be the guy you
are and so that's why I wanted to call
it like dad you know i was actually
reminded of it because of Aaron Swartz
um like I didn't meet but made a big
difference for a lot of people in on the
internet and when he killed himself a
couple weeks ago under indictment from
the federal government he's what's a
long story but he's been a freedom or an
information freedom person for a long
time
and he gave a non-ironic talk called how
to give a job how to get a job like mine
about three or four years ago and that's
prob that's what I was reminded when I
was thinking about this top so so it's
sort of an homage to kurt vonnegut and
aaron schwartz so i'll do the TLDR and
everybody know a tldr is all the
computer so all the computer scientists
in the room tldr is too long didn't read
so it's when when you when you're in the
comments in a my kind of TechCrunch
article or something like that said well
this article is really long so I didn't
really read it but here's what I think
anyway so I just give you the TLDR so
the TLDR there's three rules that I live
and what I'm going to do today is going
to talk a little bit about how I think
about the world i'll talk about my path
from sitting in a chair pretty much like
these chairs all that not as nice twenty
years ago through being an engineer and
an entrepreneur and a CEO in a VC and
then I'll talk a little bit about what
we do at greylock and how we think about
things and a little bit about what I
think the future holds so I have three
rules and it's kind of the framer the
framing here's the first thing make
things and a lot of them and as you make
things as long as you can be a maker the
best thing about Stanford is it teaches
you how to do things and put products
into the world and the people that I
interact with feel that I like being
with now are the people who really can
see things me product people and can
make things themselves the second two
rules actually both came from Tom cosmic
i'll talk about in just a second and
they've stuck with me for 20 years now
the this you're not quite his words
these are read Hoffman's words what Tom
said when I was Tom cosmic said when I
was just coming out of Stanford in 1995
he said you need to figure out that
people who you want to be on your team
you need to look around at the 22 year
olds 23 year old 24 year olds were
coming out of Stanford now in Silicon
Valley now and figure out the ones you
want to be you want to work with and
play with and collaborate with because
20 years from now you may run until
Cannavale II and that really stuck with
me and it affected the way I think and
it affected the way even that you know
my interactions with read so I'm a
partner with Reid Hoffman you find it
linkedin at greylock he and I
collaborated in a number of ways his
version of it is find your tribe figure
out who's on your side figure out who's
not on your side and be super clear
about it and invest in the people who
are on you in your tribe always
like don't it's not a static thing so
keep renewing and keep bringing people
in but really really invest in it and so
I think I can't say this super strong
enough but like the people who you work
with are just about everything our focus
on recruiting and collaboration through
my whole talk and what you'll see is
that I'll weave some of the same people
in even though I work with new people
all the time I'll weave some of the same
people in the same influences like Tom
cause Nick and Tom pires through the
whole just through my whole talk it
matters it's everything I think and then
the third thing is something tom says do
what makes your soul sing and what he
meant is that do stuff that speaks to
you so changing the world is hard mostly
people don't want change mostly the
status quo is the status quo because
people are kind of comfortable with it
and it's easier to keep it the way it is
than to change it being an entrepreneur
is super hard nobody wants like peep
nobody wants ober except for uber at the
beginning right nobody wants nobody
wants to communicate 140 character sound
by its except for Evan biz when they
started it and so you have to make the
world the way it is they're their vested
interests that want to keep the world
how it was and so because it's hard and
because it's constantly hard because
people are telling you you're a
and why things won't work over and over
and over again it's important to do
things that really speak to you and feed
your soul and help you grow over time I
think I think that I think we forget
about growth a lot of times I think we
now say well you know you're 20 or 22
and you dropped out of school you should
be able to run a multi-billion dollar
company and I think I say that kind of
tongue-in-cheek but I I submit to you
that many people believe it but I think
we forget that growth growth is human
and growth is key and so finding things
to make your soul saying that speak to
you and you love and that grow you as a
person over x is the thing those are my
rules that's it everything else is a
detail so here's the background this is
seventh grade that's me this is our key
this is our computer club in Las Vegas
so seventh grade and that's that's my
friend Adam this is nobody's going to
remember this but this is a pet this is
a Commodore pet computer or maybe the
one before the pet this is a floppy disk
drive it's got with specials that had
two floppy disk spaces and I was a
printer and I
we had one computer for the club I don't
totally remember it but Adam and I
played a lot of Zork together and I
don't nobody probably knows what that is
but was an adventure game there was not
a lot of pictures and a lot of texts and
but we did that a lot and then we split
so I moved and he moved and was
interesting because later we kind of
reconnected over the web and it turns
out that he did the same work that I did
in school so he he became a sort of
obsessed with how people use computers
and how the sociological impact and so
he started doing computer design and
computer computer interaction just like
I did so I think a lot of that goes all
the way back to what we were interested
in seventh grade so most often when
asked to identify what not what I am by
training is I say I'm a Stanford
engineered like him how many people are
engineers the room yeah so I've sat in
your seat I've fallen asleep in your
seat once or twice and I'll tell you a
story about that Clint in a second so i
did a BS in computer systems there's
like half ee and half computer science
and I did am ms in computer and computer
science and I didn't something called
HCI human-computer interaction with the
very very early days of this and I'll
tell a story about that and his second
to the bestest it Tom mentioned this but
the best decision I probably ever made
the best work decision I've ever made
was to be a section leader in stanford
and the reason was at adi school class
this morning and one of the quotes they
made is that the job of the job of the
leaders that create other leaders and
going throughout in CS 198 and helping
people learn how to teach other amazing
students at Stanford was such a
fundamental experience for me that it
changed how I thought about everything
really and it turns out that in practice
you can see this network blossoming
everywhere in Silicon Valley Marissa
Marissa Meyer from yahoo is a sectional
year Brett Taylor the former CTO of
Facebook Mike's rep for the form of the
vp engineering of Facebook all these
people are section leaders and the sort
of the the lineages are extremely
impressive when I think it all goes back
to think about how to create other
leaders and how to teach other teachers
so that was the best forgit ever made
bar none my most embarrassing moment
that I'm willing to talk about on film
was in cs5 47 in about nineteen
ninety-three when I fell asleep when
this guy from Switzerland and Robert
Kelly
brought this ridiculous box is this big
black box that's called a next computer
which is where Steve Jobs went after
Apple and he did this demo of this thing
and call the web page and I fell asleep
I was doing it and it was in it was in
skilling auditorium and I just didn't
get it cuz I saw pictures and text and
click click click click some links and
there's some other things on some list I
fell asleep and I woke up and everyone
was leaving and so anyway after that i
rallied and so I did better the thing
that I read it stands for the thing that
changed my life in might that all my
career you know when I came in to
Stanford I was really interesting the
kind of stuff that John Hennessy was
doing the you know i'll talk about
computer architecture out how to make
computers go fast fast fast and then i
had a couple of mentors at internships
that i was at its Sun which is not kind
of where you think about HCI coming from
but also here at Stanford and there was
a guy a guy my dorm is Shaun White who
will be all talk about through this
through this piece through the
conversation today and Sean kept telling
me I should do this thing called HCI
Sean was Terry monetary winograd first
very first grad students in design at a
time we were just trying to figure out
what the different scene design was and
human factors and usability in Sean said
you got to do this you'll love it and I
was resistant really resistant I was
like no no I'm a computer architecture
guy I'm going to do multi-core you know
instruction sets in silicon silicon and
obviously I just really wasn't
interested HCI and then I then I read
this piece by a guy named Mitch gay porn
and mitch mitch is the founder of Lotus
he started he was one of the first
people that really successfully
commercialized the spreadsheet and he
wrote this piece called a software
design manifesto and what he said is
this software needs architects just like
buildings need architects I think we
think about this I think it's obvious
now but it was an obvious in 1991 and
it's interesting i was just reading it
today and what he said in 1991 is that
the revolution hasn't succeeded because
what started is this very human
counterculture thing to give pcs to
people there was a revolutionary idea in
the 80s what he said is well this
just this has become the mainstream now
computers are defining us instead of us
to find computers
and when I read is when I'm going to
read this bull thing he could have
written this today and he could written
about mobile instead of computers and
phones that are computers and we could
have said is like the revolution hasn't
yet to exceed it because in spite of the
amazing progress and the amazing work
that we're doing with these things we're
still not fundamentally human in our in
our interactions of technology and again
that's it that's the thread that's red
that's led all the way through my career
and I think we're finally waking up to i
think there's Steve coming back to Apple
finally woke up the world about how
important design how important human
factors is to help what more portly how
important thing about technology in
context could be and how powerful it
could be so you know Mitch changed my
life and eventually well I'll come back
to that in a second I joined a chemical
ecology software out of Stanford and as
a VC is a funny there's a funny thing
that happens which is if you come pitch
me like I deserve hide I I believe is a
high degree of like high likelihood that
i can tell you where your first job was
if it was at Google or Apple or Amazon
and it's because when you the first
place you go out of school tends to
imprint you and you so Google they tend
to have a very very sort of lets a be
test kind of attitude you know Apple
tends to have a very very slow design
point of view Zynga it was like Google
a/b testing but like x 10 and and you
tend to really really take the lessons
of the first place you work through your
whole career trilogy the key was
recruiting all he cared about was
getting awesome awesome people and
children wasn't a successful company all
smelly and it's still around it's the
okay but but thank God I went there
because recruiting is so central and
soak or whether your startup or a
growing company now and that's been
another lesson so I think that picking
your first company whether and even
whether you choose to start up or not is
a key key decision choosing a star Joe
Kraus the founder excite and a friend
he's a partner google ventures now he
likes to say you learn more from
successful companies than you do from
failures the going off and doing your
own thing that fails you learn a lot but
you don't always learn the right things
and then going to a company successful
it's like a rocket ship and you know a
guy like matt cohler is a good example
so match
and read as he was starting linkedin and
he saw so many things going right at
linkedin and he went to he joined suck
at facebook and now he's a partner at
benchmark but i think seeing the right
seeing good examples of the right kind
of scaling the right kind of
organization building is huge I mean
failings okay too but it's not as good
as winning so then I went to apple where
I had been as an intern I learned how to
play with technology and I was in a I
was in a part of Apple that that we were
looking at education we were looking at
playfulness we're looking at children
and that was fun because I figured you I
started learning about how to tackle big
problems with small solutions and it was
when Steve came back and the happy the
happy thing for me is that Steve really
didn't like my group very much and so he
started firing everyone which caused you
know my group to die and a lot of people
that I cared about to leave and it
helped me leave to start my own company
and I was I was kind of grateful for
that but there's some interesting Steve
Steve Jobs stories and the one I'll tell
you is that he came back at a time when
the market cap of Apple was about
approximately equal to the cash we had
on hand and nobody remembers this and it
sounds ridiculous it's the time when
Microsoft was dominant son was
incredible son looked like some was
going to buy apple and I know none of
you remember this but it looked like
Apple was dead and Steve came back
because apple acquired next and then
he's took over and nobody believed in it
and I remember this town hall in a room
for 480g for the advanced technology
group I'm about this size and steve was
up on stage and in the in the press the
day before the press had asked Michael
Dell who started dell computer what
apple should do it's like well i
think they should give the mic back to
the shareholders and shut the thing down
so obviously he's got some some point
it's now given the things that the dells
going through in the ten how Apple son
since then but you know so somebody so
Steve get this big talk where they're
going to reinvent apple and somebody
asked him look what do you think about
what Michael Dell said and in the Steve
pause he's think we'll Michael Dell
and I'm no joke said that guy and
so he said you know what we're gonna do
we're gonna reinvent the company yeah
I'm sorry I know it's broadcast out you
know i am who i am you eight second
delay or something you should we should
pause it give me any second delay
because it's gonna happen again um so um
anyway so so Steve Steve said you know
what we're going to build a great
company we're going to reinvent the
world and anybody who believes me like
let's let's get moving if you don't
believe that happen then get the hell
out and this was an amazing active
leadership because it was so clear who
was in and who was out I'll tell you
people in the room would have followed
Steve everywhere and anywhere Alma just
about anywhere now turns out me and my
friends left and we're happy with that
decision although you know economically
it probably have been better to stick
around we've all done okay but the but
what I'm an active leadership by a guy
who nobody believed in at a time nobody
believed it so after that I left and I
started my company called reactivity and
I don't know what to say about
reactivity it's it's I'll tell you being
a founder is such a complex set of
things like you know we started in my in
my in my kitchen with my mentor from
apple and my best friend from Stanford
who was a section leader and in one of
the people who was went through the HCI
program with me at Stanford and I still
can't process it exactly i'm very very
proud of what we built we eventually
sold it to cisco a few years later but
you know again I think the recruiting
and mentors and connections was the
thing you know we got Mitch k port
invest in us from Excel I've
collaborated on him and a number of
things and he was the way I eventually
got to Mozilla there's another guy from
Excel named Peter friend he's our
partner of benchmark and Peter's date on
the board longer than I did it's longer
than I lasted the company so I was there
for seven years Peter lasted two more
years beyond that and you know as I see
so many founders now think about venture
investing or getting that a round is a
transaction I just need to get this done
as fast I can and get the money in the
bank and move on it's such a crazy point
of view from from my perspective because
you're going to be with these people for
years they're going to affect the way
you think you're going to affect the way
they think you're going to have hot up
times down time you're going to yell at
each other you can go through happy
times and like it's really really
careful it's as important how to choose
your investors as it is how to choose
your management teams if you can fire
your management team you can't fire
investors and so I don't know I was I
was very very lucky because I didn't
really understand how far reaching a
decision that was when I took money from
Mitch and Peter it worked out very very
well for us emotionally and in its
business as well and then the best
accident of my career is that I joined
Mozilla so in 2005 I was going through
this period rush trying to figure out
what to do and I thought I thought I was
going to do venture and I just couldn't
find the right venture firm for me then
and I accidentally because of Mitch I
accidentally got sort of involved with
the Mozilla people and Mozilla at the
time had just launched Firefox about
three or four months earlier they had
just signed a deal with google that made
it economically viable it was an
open-source nonprofit which is not
exactly what you're looking for when
you're doing a job search but I couldn't
I couldn't I couldn't escape it I felt
this incredible story strong
gravitational pull to go work on the
browser because the web felt so
important and so under pressure at the
time and again you won't remember this
but I'll show you why that's important
so this is what it looked like just
before I got there and again you're not
gonna remember this so Microsoft was
dominant dominic dominant ninety-six
percent of the computers in the world
now I see all I see how here is max that
wasn't the case in two thousand four
ninety percent of the computers in the
world that people use for windows and
all of them all of them used internet
explorer so those are bats this is such
as such a finished chapter the Microsoft
took their Internet Explorer team and
they said you guys are not working x
internet explorer anymore mission
accomplished and they put them all on
silverlight which is as you know is
going to be huge
this is a mistake that Microsoft made it
took them years and years and years to
come back from it I would argue that it
really it really opened the door for a
quick downfall for Microsoft four years
later in 2008 we were about a quarter
market share nine percent is opera and
Safari and some other stuff and then now
this is this is IE about fifty five
percent penny count this is chrome and
this is Firefox again depending on how
you count and this is some other stuff
safari in Safari and opera and if you if
you include mobile the world changes
quite dramatically and I'll show that in
just a second but for most of those
point of view this is what we wanted
like we didn't want the same as this but
orange we wanted robust we probably we
probably could have you happy with the
blue slightly smaller but but but this
is what we wanted we wanted a robust
competitive market where you had people
people innovating and trying to be good
for consumers because we felt like that
was that was our mission of a non-profit
I feel like in large part we made that
happen it's more to talk about how we
made it happens we were this funky odd
like open source thing that nobody much
understood and I'll tell you I think it
took Microsoft right two years to figure
what the hell we were doing and and and
I say that because we weren't trying to
be them we weren't going to trade shows
we weren't doing deals with Dell we
weren't doing any of this what we
were doing is we are trying to find the
biggest community we could and make them
all owners make as many people
responsible for translation and code and
distribution and user interfaces we
could and I show this picture this is a
picture the internet you know a while
ago it was smaller then and what the
internet especially is called it's a
system called chaotic systems and
carrick systems are sort of half chaos
and half order but they're they're
roughly there they're kind of their
multi nodal systems or you have multi
nodal authority and no center or no
center of gravity and so that's what the
internet is and that's what Mozilla is
in many ways so we had people who
responsible we really gave them
responsibility whether they worked for
us or not and it was just we competed
asymmetrically we were open source they
didn't understand Microsoft didn't
understand what to do with that how can
you compete if you give you
source code away we were
community-driven we were nonprofit like
it turns out that mozilla makes many
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
now and we profit a significant portion
of that so nonprofit is more of a
mission statement that is a balance
sheet statement we're pretty we're a
pretty successful nonprofit I'm sort of
obsessed with nonprofit sustainability
which is what I'm involved in code for
america and other nonprofits now we
didn't try to be them I think that's
true too i was talking to be able to
dees cool this morning and the success
the most interesting successful
companies that scale facebook linkedin
pandora Unity's i think they're all
different and so they're not all afraid
to rethink back to first principles how
to run the company Google doesn't run
like Apple in the slightest but they're
both interesting meaningful companies
and so I think a lot of times you get
caught up with how do we act like a
professional management team or how do
we act like a you know an establishment
company I think the most interesting
companies don't do that the most
interesting companies think about well
who are we and how are we successful in
that context and what do we need to add
to be different than who we are now and
then ultimately we involve millions
millions and millions of nodes and
millions of people and we try to help
have everybody like a political movement
feel like we needed them to be
successful and I think that's that's the
key I think to a lot of community
project which is you have to be
successful enough that people can see
promise but fragile enough that they
they think they think they need that you
need their help and the example give is
it I'll show my political leanings just
briefly in 2008 I made phone calls for
for the Obama campaign so I called a
bunch of people on Election Day in
western Pennsylvania which was
illuminating and and I told them that
should get out to vote and I did it
because I thought it was a thing worth
doing and I thought Obama mind I win if
I didn't go call and that sounds
ridiculous but I think that's the key I
think nobody wants to go join a thing
where they where they don't need you and
so you need to have a project that has
promised but still needs you that's
that's central so Mozilla was a pretty
happy accident for me and then
about two years ago this month I joined
a firm called Greylock partners and I'll
do just a quick version we lost one of
the oldest VC firms for a billion dollar
fund we're on our 13th fun now there's
eight of us who are active investors
we've all operated six of us have
founded companies to people have found
in come one one of them founded a
company while he's at greylock that's
now called it's called work day it's one
of the most successful IPOs this year
another one founded it before he got the
Grail out called LinkedIn which is a
pretty meaningful company too and so we
all have operated scale which means you
know we've all been around very very
special ramps very very special
companies and so we all are able to help
we all love product we all have the
sense to leave things alone when they're
working and really have the
entrepreneurs the genius the
entrepreneur blow it out I think we can
all help when they when they struggle
software-only enterprise software
consumer internet all stages I think I
were in a 50,000 hour check and a 30
million-dollar check that presents its
own challenges it's a heart it's a big
big spectrum of things you're able to do
this is who we are I mean over the past
24 months we've had a ton of exits and
the exits are interesting but it's all
work that my partner's did you know five
ten years ago in the downturn I think
the morning work is the is that what one
and two percent companies are doing the
garage now who will show up on this
chart when i'm back in a few years maybe
this mostly will look like any other VC
will put up but i'll give some color on
it for a second in a second great
products great teams and when i say get
all the way to the finish line what i
mean is you're not looking for a
condition you're looking for a make a
big fundamental durable company and
there just aren't very many of those and
I'll illustrate that in just a second
and then we kind of obsessed about
distribution probably more than any
other firm we're focused on distribution
because whether it's enterprise software
consumer like the key is like how do you
get enough people to give a damn about
your project and product and use it
that's a that's a simple question and a
really brutally hard question to answer
so we care about distribution and
highlight in a second so very large very
durable companies so since the beginning
of the Internet give or take the web
1995 so maybe 17 years ago
many consumer Internet companies which
is where I focus these foes are on the
public markets they're worth more than a
billion billion dollars do you think
it's 50 or 100 or tan or invite have any
guesses 15 it's more than 10 but it's
not many more than 10 the answer is 24
so but if you really parse this out 24
is not a very big number 15 years 20 for
companies and so because like look I'll
show you my calendar a second so I I met
I meet about 300 to 400 companies every
year and when I'm telling you use that
one and a half companies a year between
1995 and now are worth more than a
billion dollars on the public markets
that's crazy because I don't even see
most of the country I see some fraction
of consumer companies in 350 foreign
companies so here the 24 it's kind of
interesting actually don't know what
vistaprint does like I'm you know
ancestor what's that no thank you you
know we were lucky to be involved in
some of them so how many people how many
of these do you think are worth more
than 10 billion dollars because every
firm will tell you they want to invest
in multi-billion dollar companies device
counting it's not half seven that's it
so this list I submit so this is the
consumer internet not the not that and
there's other things in the enterprise
which has a number of companies there's
you know little companies like Apple and
others that are that are pretty big on
the hardware side but this is the seven
consumer Internet companies that are 10
billion or more public market cap
independent companies now so it's worth
looking at those and understanding
what's special about them and
understanding what's what's similar and
what's different from our point of view
all of these everyone except for maybe
maybe priceline maybe yahoo you get
serious networked effects serious
distribution advantages as you get
bigger and bigger to scale we tend to be
obsessed with things that have in baked
in network advantages because it lets
you get big quickly and let's you be
robust for a long time ebay i mean ebay
has gone through
so many challenges yahoo too but like
the they're built in distribution
effects have kept them alive for a long
time and now they're another both in a
period of reinvention so let me give you
a brief asada morality which probably
the most overused term that I here so
most people say what our product is
totally viral and what they mean is
their product people are going to love
their products so much they're going to
talk about it to their friends so for us
that's not viral for us the specific and
actual definition of viral is it's
useful for me to get all of you on the
system because that makes me want to go
turn all of you into users so photo
sharing is something that was photo
photo taking on the iphone so you know
you first got your camera photo taking
wasn't viral in any way it wasn't
network effect you take your picture
then it's on your hard drive what
Instagram did what Kevin and Mikey did
is they created a system where for me to
get value I had to turn all you guys
into instagram users that's viral and
that's a special that's a special kind
of network characteristic anything else
is basically word of mouth maybe network
effects but morality is a really special
thing and the thing I like about this
definition which came from Reed is it's
really actionable it really starts to
get you to think it's like oh I'm i'm
using this in our single player mode i'm
thinking about this is a one person
product but now how do i think about it
if i want to use it with my wife or my
dad or my cousin or my classmate and
that's a really powerful way to unlock
on the consumer internet this idea of
network network effects network spread
so here's the bottom line that
everybody's going to tell you they want
to invest in the multi-billion dollar
companies and i guess i should say to
that venture capital is not all the same
it's very different funds different
things for us and maybe a handful of
others we look for is the facebook style
returns the linkedin star returns big
big durable companies that are going to
be fundamental and landscape changing
what that means is as a matter of course
you make a lot of mistakes because its
heart you're peering through a glass
darkly but this is what we this is what
we try to do it almost never happens 24
times on the consumer in the last 15
years and there's a few more that got
bought like Instagram and YouTube but
and a few more on the sidelines like
square and some others that are that are
looking pretty good but when you do it
you change everything
so my my profile so just some quick
observations about VC like this is my
this is my heat map for my calendar from
2012 and so the the red days or days and
I had eight or more meetings in the
orange days or days and I had you know
five or six so kind of lighter days and
then the yellow days maybe I had two or
three meetings and the only reason June
looks like that it's because my wife and
I had our second child so I try to take
fewer meetings a month in truth I didn't
take any means I he's probably like
going to the gym and stuff like that so
here's the thing and I didn't really
understand this when I was an
entrepreneur and so I'm trying to
communicate to as many people as I can
venture capitalists all they do all day
is they try to find the best
entrepreneurs they can and they try to
respond to as many entrepreneurs as they
can and they try to the best ones try to
be helpful and add value what that means
is you might a lot of you sees will see
400 300 companies a year and most dc's
invest in two or three companies years
that's one percent as you say 99 times
you say no no you're like not for me
which as a maker it's a hard thing to do
as a guy who see who comes in like what
you're doing is everybody's coming in
and they're pitching you what the future
is going to be they can see it it's
already finished for them you can the
best entrepreneurs can see the future
and what you're doing is you say okay
like I get this i get the use you can
see the future I it's just not for me
and so sometime it's a very hard thing
because sometimes you're saying because
you don't believe it sometimes you're
saying is you don't like it sometimes
you're saying it for any variety of
reasons but say 99 nose for everyone yes
that's a that's a tough ratio and it's
useful to understand it contest
switching is brutal so you can have like
even in just the consumer internet this
is why we specialize a little bit you
might see a photo sharing app and a you
know you can see a lot of photo-sharing
apps but um but you'll see a lot of
different things in the in the course of
just one day and you'll try to be
helping your portfolio companies at the
same time and you'll be trying to think
like how to help your partners and
everything so it's it's a it's a lot of
context switching and as a result time
is everything so since you're only doing
one or two to new companies a year it
really is key like you might just be
busy so you know we passed on tumblr on
on pinterest twice in 2011 the first
time we did it because we just didn't
able to get big which turned out to be
not true in the second time you did it
it was just hard for us to run after
because i was i was in the house in the
middle of finishing up investment and
tumblr so tumblr was kind of related and
we couldn't really pay attention to it
and so you know it went by in a way that
we couldn't really regret I couldn't
really aggressively pursue so timing
really really is everything and then
here's the thing that I think nobody
really kind of internalizes like we're
all super super quirky and super
idiosyncratic just like any other
collection of humans so every firms
different every person is different and
you really have to understand who the
person is that you're talking to not all
I want to pitch it on a pitch Excel or
gray Locker sequoia so very very least
impressed we all make decisions
differently we all prosecute things
differently we all think about things
differently this is what happened to my
first 24 months I've done five
investments citrus lane ecommerce for
moms clear slide it we're trying to sort
of a business after trying to kill WebEx
for salespeople tumblr Dropbox Instagram
you probably know you know one thing
that's worth mentioning citrus lane was
a mayfield fellow named mariah Finley he
started that company CS major and master
student clear sliders guy mal liebe
who's a computer scientist from Stanford
who started evite now he's the CEO
tumblers got him David Karp who dropped
out of high school in ninth grade in New
York and taught himself how to code
Dropbox was Drew MIT computer scientist
and instagram is kevin and mikey
symbolic systems majors from Stanford so
I like makers I like people who are
passionate about product who make things
who really are desperate to build things
that people love and for me that's been
most fruitful has been it look in places
engineering schools design schools and
that's that's where I hunt more often
than not and it's not to say you can't
be like that as an MBA a lot of MBAs
good tweet when I say that I think I
think anybody can be a great product
person as long as you have the passion
and the ability to follow up in the
details on product and make them great
so that's my first 24 months who will
see Instagram is slightly funky
investment because we wire the money on
Thursday and Kevin some email and Sunday
today were getting acquired that was
unusual
so here's the future I'll give you three
charts and then we'll open up for
questions this is the whole thing this
is where I spend all my day thinking
about this is the Internet in the past
five years it's grown a lot so almost
doubled and it's useful and instructive
to see where it's growing I think more
most of the many of the interesting
communication apps like lion and cacao
we're seeing coming at Asia North
America is pretty well saturated I think
in hope is a citizen of the earth that
we're going to see more and more growth
at a Latin America Africa this is pretty
meaningful this is a bit of an eye chart
but what it is is between 1975 and 2011
oh by the way this is a tsimko a tsimko
he should all read this blog he's during
a conference today but he writes some of
the most thoughtful stuff about how
devices are proliferating in the world
everybody should read it what this says
is in a logarithmic scale thousands of
users units per year between 1975 and
2011 what do we ship and so what you can
see is like well here's a trs-80 which
again I guess I'm an old guy so trs-80 I
remember here's the next not Steve
wasn't for a six he wasn't always
successful you know here's the Commodore
64 which is awesome the Macintosh that
you let yellow line the pc is this big
line but what I want you to notice is
like this period here nothing was
happening the pc and mac and i'll show
it to you in a better way in just a
minute but now everything's happening
we're seeing a Cambrian explosion of
devices and streams and sensors
everything is in play right now um look
the other way I'll show it to you is
this way so this is what this chart I
call the dark ages of computing so the
blue is windows so from 1987 till
recently windows dominated and not so as
I was putting this together yesterday
I'm like man this looks like the dark
ages it looked like we fell off the map
innovation stopped it was dominated by
just microsoft and in the snarky part of
me says innovation of Microsoft during
that period is probably an oxymoron
but it wasn't a good time you had this
little bit of Macintosh but Macintosh
wasn't a very good time either we're
going to get bought for the amount of
cash we had right this sucked it sucks
sucked but now it doesn't so this
is 2011 and it's getting better so now
you've got I read from the other day
that for the first time quite 20 years
more than fifty percent of emails were
read not without look it's because it's
on your phone it's because it's in your
tablet and phone and on your TV's this
is going to change everything for the
first time we've got this incredibly
like high-energy explosion I think think
things are in chaos so the question to
you guys is there's white space so we
don't know yet whether we'll go into
this dark ages where one of these
dominates for another 20 years I hope
not and I kind of don't think so because
I think that the amount of the amount of
our lives we are mediating through
mobile through computing generally is
getting higher and higher and higher but
so my views were exiting the dark ages
everything is in chaos everything is a
promise they're going to be a bunch of
funny starts there's gonna be a bunch of
things that they grow and get big and
disappear off the face of the earth just
like the sort of Cambrian explosion
right precambrian closing or like the
Renaissance will have lots and lots and
lots of ideas and this is the time we're
living in now so the question for you
guys is what will you put there and this
is like this is the essence of
entrepreneurship which is like well I
see that map I see how it sucked before
but I'm going to draw it my way now
that's I'll tell you that's the most
exciting chart in the whole time that
I've been in and around computing so I'm
going to do recap three simple rules
make things you'll make a lot of
mistakes the more you make the more
you'll get right find your tribe choose
to work with people you care about and
you can live with and you want to
collaborate for a long time and then do
what make sure your soul saying and then
i'm going to give one kotas i'm going to
give a gratuitous jim harbaugh picture
when I stand for a year so the thing I
like about Harbaugh he's a little nutty
but um I like him better this is this is
my favorite horrible picture because it
was after the USC game where we may have
gone for two when we had a USC by maybe
30 points and Pete Carroll goes what's
your deal and Jim Harbaugh goes what's
your deal and then they run
field anyway so I liked Harbaugh but
he's got this thing that he took the
49ers from his family and he has people
who's got it better than us and so I
would just say you guys all sitting here
at Stanford at Stanford at a place where
the computer science departments strong
where you've got many many not just one
or two entrepreneurship professors but
people running whole programs at a
university run by an entrepreneur and an
engineer in the middle of capital
mentors entrepreneurs companies like
there's no way it's got better than you
be able do now and so I would just say
that there's nobody that's in a better
position to change the rule now then
there's ever been really so I think with
that I'll think we'll go to QA and it'll
go from there okay
so question sure you're realistic 24 hat
what I think might be first market
companies and what not on the list that
you've identified skype one of the
already voice oh yeah let's go on and
when I look at that is where they're
perfectly challenges that kept them up
man oh so the question is well they're a
bunch of first American companies that
show up and disappear and I guess I
don't know I don't know I haven't done
the analysis on why that happened one
day that's worth mentioning is that what
we did at Mozilla was attacking an
incumbent market which was pretty static
at a time and that's a different thing
that what's a Instagram did which was on
mobile you've got greenfield and you're
trying to go as fast as you can so it's
pretty important to understand the field
you're playing on and you're right that
he's you look back historically me what
i did was mostly illustrators say look
billion company is hard and so yeah once
you get once you get big once you get
public recruiting it's brutal and I
think that's truer now than it's been
ever next question sure you mentioned
that one of every 100 companies did you
see so what else thinking that it might
create some mindset and you that you
might become very negative towards
investors look towards investments in so
do don't use any tools or are they but
some things that you say yourself before
you get into a meeting so you don't want
to the truck over negative yeah so the
question is if you say no 99 times does
that make you a little bit negative and
isn't that it doesn't create a jaded or
cynic cynicism trap and I think that's
true um I'll tell you it when you say 90
99 times it doesn't mean you're not
interested in 99 of the meetings so a
lot almost every meeting is interesting
almost every meeting you can learn
something from and almost and I think
every and every meeting somebody is
sacrificing much of their lives to make
this thing this this feature that they
can see true and so I think it's our job
not to be jaded and I think that if you
get jaded too much and if you find
yourself there you sort of shake
yourself and try to get better if you
can't shake yourself and you shouldn't
do investing anymore as my view so I'm
the new guys I'm two years in
this I'm not jaded yet and I'll tell you
that you have one meeting with an
entrepreneur in a year that turns into
an awesome working relationship to last
for years or decades that's enough next
question sure what's the biggest reason
that you turn down people do you look
more at the like the potential and the
idea or as a potential in the person the
question is what's the reason I turned
down companies I guess is that the lack
of potential of the idea are like
potential in the person and I don't know
look after after an hour meeting I don't
know anything about about about you
really and that's that's one of the
things you got understands the VC is
like you're doing lots and lots and lots
of one hour meetings and what you know
you're not doing very end up things and
so what you're trying to figure out is
people you're interested in learning
more about overtime I would say there's
there are bars that you have to get over
in terms of market size distribution
characteristics product quality
demonstration that the person knows how
to make things and then I think you just
try to figure out whether it's the one
for you or not like a lot of things I
turned out it's not doesn't resonate
with me I think they'll do really well
it just doesn't it's not for me the ones
I think it's easier to say why you like
things and you say i'm going to invest
it's because you believe in the person
and you believe in the market and you
believe in the in the in the product and
when those two things come together
that's that's the key so it's easier to
say what what the positive
characteristics are than the negative
for me sure so they convey see ya ok
back at being an engineer CEO why don't
you know like what do you think you like
most so question is what I said why did
I try to be what I decided white why did
I decide to BBC sorry and then which I
meant to answer them in their
presentation then the second question
was which which job of i like the most
or what role i decided to be VC except
thought it could be good at it and i
thought i would like it that seems like
kind of obvious right I thought I could
like would like it if I could be good at
it fundamentally I've had a really good
time building ventures and building
management teams
Mozilla was probably the most fun thing
I've ever done I like working with great
people and great entrepreneurs and it's
not more complicated than that this felt
like something that I could be really
good at and have a really good time at
as far as roles i don't know like um I
think you should my own journey is I've
always tried to find things that I could
be world class at so I've always tried
to find things that I could make the
biggest difference in the world and be I
don't know one of the top 5 10 20 people
in the world at it which I'm clearly not
as a vcm clearly I'm new and you know
when I came out of Stanford I was a HDR
I was well when I was undergrad I was a
programmer and I realized really quickly
I could never be a world-class
programmer and I can find other people
to be programmers but I wanted to be a
designer so I when he desire it was
really clear really fast that I was not
ever going to be a world-class designer
but could that could be good at it I
would never be a top 20 designer in the
world but I thought I could be that for
organizations and so when I came out of
Stanford I started managing a group a
trilogy and I started managing people an
apple and installed my own company and I
felt the organizationally like I feel
some competence at and and I say that
kind of in a specific way cuz i really
feel like as soon as you feel like you
know things like you start to be kind of
stupid and I feel like organizations and
inventors in particular is a learning
process that's continual so everything
everything is new so I don't know you
know I'm two years into this job people
tell me it takes a few years to figure
out what to do what your style is and
say it's a figure a few years after
that's figure out what your style is any
good or not I'd like to make it shorter
than that so that's what I'm trying to
work on but I don't know I like all the
jobs I have and they're all frustrating
to you know columns and your experience
of working with women CEOs and how they
navigated that sort of question
this feels like a complex question so
the question is the question is can i
comment on work-life balance but it
seems to me like the question you're
actually entering is the other asking is
the other part about women CEOs and the
challenges and how they've navigated so
how I a is there's not there not
enough women entrepreneurs they're not
enough women CEOs there are not enough
women executives or not affluent
scientists are not fluent in the
workplace generally I think it's a
brutal problem I think that it starts
very early and I think that but i think
that's not the only problem i think that
the expectations around families and
caregiving there's also another problem
you know we're going I have a
seven-year-old son but also a
six-month-old seven month old son and
you know i look at my wife is he's had
to take a pause from the workplace
because we prioritized that work for her
now in it it's I think challenging
challenging no way around it you know
Mariah I found it I'm in Mariah's board
my affiliate citrus lane she's got two
small kids and she's she's amazing she
works really hard and she really
prioritizes her family I don't I
couldn't quite tell you how she does
that i'm also on the boards of two
nonprofits that have female leaders
Mitchell Baker at Mozilla and Jen Palka
at Code for America and they're
incredible just full stop incredible so
I don't know how to answer that except
that we need more we need more people
thinking about it it is a hard problem
that I don't know how to solve at a
micro level other than to just keep
trying other questions sir fine i will
leave define social entrepreneurship and
what do you think about control in
emerging markets how do i define social
entrepreneurship and how do i think
about its role in emerging markets I
think entrepreneurship it full stop is
like having a view like I said having a
view of how the world is going to needs
to be or will be and then making it
happen that way social entrepreneurship
I think in my view is like how do you do
that in a way that creates a social
outcome as a top line as opposed to a
economic I lines out comes the top line
this will we did in Mozilla that was the
goal was not to make a lot of money the
goal was to make the intern
at open and participatory in a way at a
time we thought it was not code for
america is to make citizenship better
and to help more of us be citizens you
know I think that we're going to see
more and more of these because the
Internet's driving down costs to start
technology costs and like the cost to
find people who are like-minded and have
a similar vision of the world to you
it's going to almost 20 and so you get
all jealous like Kiva and encode from
American others distribution costs Ron
10 almost at zero now too so I think
that and then I think the thing I'm
obsessed with is how do you fund social
enterprises or not-for-profit
enterprises how do you fund them in the
market which is what I'm so proud of
what we did in Mozilla which is we used
search and some other things to fund
this nonprofit mission I think that's
totally possible because you're driving
cost 20 I don't know much about the
emerging developing world to be honest
with you we did a lot of work there and
we had a lot of adoption at with firefox
in Latin America and Africa I don't know
I think we're probably learn some things
about how people deploy wireless
networks and our people live their lives
on on mobile phones from developing
nations pretty quickly so i guess i'm
hopeful i think that the the basic
equation though is driving costs down
2-0 to start these things then you can
start which means you don't need as much
sort of voracious growth to run the
things over time other question sure
yeah so the question is how do I stay
productive to context switches and
out fine the kind of depends on the day
some days are better than others and
some i'll tell you when i was when i was
an operating executive i would come home
and my wife would asking what i did and
I'd say well we did this and this and
this other amazing thing and she asked
me what I did now if mostly I have to
look at my calendar say I'm not sure
because like the the 8am meeting was
eight context ago and so it's a tough
challenge so I think that my the thing
that I struggle with the most and thing
that I that I find other interesting
investors struggled the most is like how
do you number one how do you live in
your outbox more than your inbox so how
do you decide
like an entrepreneur how do you decide
what the effect you on the world to be
is how do you find that decide what the
interesting things are and how you may
go after them as opposed to being
reactive to everybody else you want your
time but the trick is like how do you do
that and still remain accessible and
responsive to many many people who want
your help so I would tell you that I
think everybody could struggles with
this and I don't have a good history yet
sure my dish is just about how do you
said you want to find your tribe um and
what I was wondering is is how you go up
go up to your not what types of people
of those are for you personally yeah
that's that's a good question I didn't
anticipate um who just happened so how
do you find your tribe how you figure
out who's in and who you want to be
around if it's worth it I don't know
Coney Stanford was probably pretty good
start and you know one of the one of the
I think there Warren Buffett's got this
quote I think that it's like what you
try to find people to work with is
people who have integrity energy and
intelligence because if they don't have
the first one the other two will kill
you right and so it's like without
integrity like the intelligence and
energy will totally screw you up right
and so there's there's some there's some
some baseline things like you you have
to you you just have to figure out where
your integrity line is on all that stuff
and what fundamental values are
important to you beyond that I think you
got to try hard to put yourself in
situations that are hard and one of the
I haven't ever given this talk but I've
got a title for a talk on I guess some
time which is called the vert on the
virtues of getting your ass kicked and
and what I'll tell you is that I've got
my ass kicked so many times and when I
got to Stanford I was gonna be a physics
major until I got like a C+ in physics
63 right and it was so clear that I was
not not able to cope with those guys um
you know when I was in the cs 198 the
thing I'd say was the most important
decision I ever made well they turned me
down the first quarter i applied they
took me down the first quarter and then
i applied via the coordinator they turn
me down the first two quarters and then
the third time i applied i got to be a
coordinator the first time i looked to
be a VC I didn't really find
attained the first time I started
companies may find the right thing you
know I've got partners Reid who go from
thing to thing and success to success
that's never been my experience and I
don't know I think that if you are
really aggressive and try to put
yourself into hard situations where the
people around you kick your ass all the
time so being at a table in our
partnership it's a it's a it's a
murderer's row so people invested in
created the biggest SAS companies in the
world the biggest networking companies
in the world Facebook's of billions of
dollars and returns and I'm the new guy
with five investments in we'll see how
it goes it's an intimidating table to
sit at and and then it's intimating to
to say things you do you do the best you
can and then peel say well that's called
the dumbest thing I've heard all day and
you know notin hubby's we clear no do
great Alex ever said that to me although
I'm pretty sure they thought it but the
but you know if it's always the dumbest
thing today that's fine because then
you'll learn you'll get better so that's
what I would say it's just like be
clearing your integrity and then put
yourself into situations that are hard
hard hard sure you're the white space
shark looks a lot like where is not as
you look at the ozz so the question is
the chart the the Dominus chart looks a
lot like the banking industry which is
not kind disrupted at all you know how
do I think about the banking industry
and opportunities there and i don't know
like Instagram dropbox tumblr that's my
kind of thing how we tell stories to
each other the banking industry I'm
interested in because I think that but I
think every every system we use is about
to get blown up I mean you think about
how different like five or six years ago
like we weren't using YouTube every day
or using Facebook every day we didn't
have phones we didn't get we you know
when you're out and about and your
seven-year-old son asks what difference
between Kit Fisto and you know CAD Bane
is and clone wars like you didn't have
an iphone to pull out and like look it
up on Google right but now I know
the blood sitter between every pokemon
card ever so i would say that
everything's changed so quickly but i
think we're still at the very very very
beginning so i would just say every
system that doesn't look like it's a
native mobile real time system it's all
gonna get busted up there's opportunity
everywhere so I don't have very good
banking answers and that my partner read
probably would given his experience at
PayPal but things were hard banking is
hard but it'll be it'll blow up sure one
more question oh they approach you and
what the stroke I mean is it a bad
feeling that creating those are you here
division long time + reset with no end
of a something has to clip but that are
the two questions in one is like how do
you approach and this best way to
approach is by somebody who I've worked
with every VC responds best to people
they've worked with and it's not it's
not a big it's not a big test to figure
out who's in my network now and the day
of LinkedIn and Facebook that's the best
way to come in or you know to meet at
some of these things but in general it's
do it through a person we know and yes
about how do you know whether it's brain
or gut and I guess a question sorry I
forgot to tell now tell us and we'll
finish up is the reason I decided to
join Mozilla is I got invited to a
meeting with the founders and head yahoo
where we're meeting Jerry Yang and it
was an hour long meeting and Jerry shows
up 45 minutes late we were kind of
tooling our thumbs that some of the
people who worked for them and he starts
in 2005 he starts to yell at us yell
yell yell because he was so pissed that
people yahoo users would download
Firefox and become Google users you so
angry and I what before that meeting I
was kinda on the fence whether to join
Mozilla or not but is in the middle of
while middle of I was yelling at us and
look I don't know Jerry at all I mean
he's yelling me a couple times but and I
supposed to be a very very nice guy and
I guess he probably bought one of these
building or something but the
but it was while he's yelling at us I
said well you can get a billionaire to
yell to yell at you you're probably I'm
pretty good you're probably nosing
around a pretty good space so that's
that's the key is like you're trying to
figure out whether you love the product
well you're going to get people to yell
at you so it's a good big space and
whether there's a bit of a passion or
chemistry and like anything else okay
thank you very much
you